j'aimerais qu'on écoute anas leur action
nationale est il un parti raciste pour
vous anas et oui moi je veux les
réconcilier déjà je pense que le
rassemblement national comme castaner
sont tous les deux raciste la réalité
c'est que déjà le front national c'est
ça son son histoire c'est la fondation
notamment avec léon gautier qui était un
veuf nss car fondé le front national
c'est possible on essaie de
dédiabolisant dix ans mais c'était
c'était son père jean marie le pen
marine le pen elle et elle était
porte-parole de la campagne de
jean-marie le pen si elle était
condamnée justement pour toutes les
atrocités qu'il a dit autour notamment
de delachaux à ces menaces a même été le
président d'honneur jean messia il
lui-même il s'étonne par exemple des
livreurs de hubert pendant le ramadan
parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas à 21h le
moment du ramadan en fait il n'a pas son
sandwich et et du coup ça ça va faire
l'offre moment là il ya des ennemis il
ya des immigrés qui les intéressent mais
au-delà de ça le rassemblement national
le c'est un parti qui est profondément
raciste xénophobe mais c'est aussi un
parti qui est profondément anti ouvriers
en fait c'est un parti qui en fait
méprise les prolétaires méprise des
petites gens méprisent les gens qui sont
au quotidien sont en train de lutter moi
tout ce matin j'étais aux côtés des
égoutiers des éboueurs de la ville de
paris qui luttent justement contre la
réforme de du de de la fonction publique
j'ai des camarades de l'infra paul de
paris nord qui sont en grève depuis
quatre mois
il ya des mecs de picardie il ya des
mecs qui viennent du fin fond de du 19e
arrondissement ou guyancourt il ya des
noirs des arabes des blancs et militent
ensemble ils se battent ensemble depuis
plus de quatre mois
c'est ça la réalité en fait que nous on
voit au quotidien le problème c'est que
quand on a marine le pen va dire que le
smic horaire ses 36 euros ils sont dans
plein de magouilles
on le voit encore aujourd'hui sur les
histoires d'assistants parlementaires
européens la réalité c'est que le
rassemblement national
il est ce ce caractère là mais il faut
pas oublier castaner parce que castaner
c'est aussi les bornes your de gilet
jaune c'est celui qui a fait une
politique ultra répressif c'est celui
qui a mis en place notamment les
prémices de la loi séparatisme soit au
moment de l'agression de l'islam aux
séries mais moi je n'irai pas en fait
castaner qui a dit que la la
la prière appuyer ou renforcée pendant
le ramadan que celui qui jeûne pendant
le ramadan c'est des signes de
radicalité et la réalité c'est que ces
gens-là et jean messia je peux je
partage qui vient d en renvoyant
l'histoire de de gaulle et mitterrand
etc
c'est que la réalité c'est que la
bourgeoisie de manière générale elle a
toujours été profondément raciste et
bien sûr le rassemblement national c'est
l'extrême droite le secteur local
actionnaires guillaume genton il est en
mesure de lire le nommer leur assemblée
nationale est quand même beaucoup moins
raciste parce que il a tué personne leur
sélectionneur vous entend pas changer ce
régime sit in dans la baie de seine le
pays il n'entend jamais là
[Rires]
alors oui non pour est pragmatique et
quand même des millions de français
oserait il rassembla les qui sont pas
racistes pour autant donc je pense que
c'est un peu un cliché est un raccourci
peut-être qui date de l'époque du front
national mais tout le parti a quand même
un peu évolué il ya peut-être des
racistes rassemblement national mais
aussi des racistes dans d'autres partie
pourquoi le racisme doit attribuer à un
seul parti politique c'est différent un
parti politique est raciste
non mais la polémique a rassemblé
mensuel est raciste des gens que des
mêmes des ouvriers qui vaudra semblement
nationale c'est indéniable oui il ya des
gens qui vient le beau père et moi j'ai
des collègues autour de moi qu'il ya
déjà ya des colères autour de moi qui
sont les riches qui sont pris parfois
parle envie de se dire je vais voter
rassemblement national mais jamais par
rapport à l'idéologie qui est collée au
rassemblement national c'est la question
du chaos danse et pour fixer à noir
d'envoi pour essayer de mettre un grand
coup d'arrêt dans la nasse
mais moi ces gens là je leur dis mais
réveillez vous en faites penser que vaut
aussi pour le rassemblement national un
parti qui vont de père en fille en fête
de génération en génération se refilent
le pouvoir dans lequel il ya des
énarques à des gens qui n'ont jamais
travaillé de leur kit explique que c'est
paris qui a fermé world poule qui
t'explique que c'est mamadou qui a fermé
ford blanquefort qui t'explique que
c'est khadija qu'à fermer
bridgestone et 800 emplois en fait ils
vont aller chercher la misère ils vont
aller essayer de récupérer la misère en
disant regarde tu as vu l'arabe là bas
ça cause de lui que l'ama dans cette
année ils vont vite et les milliardaires
tu peux laisser les oignons ils sont
toujours de leur côté en dernière
instance et en première instance
aujourd'hui on est en face de toi fais
tu pour défendre le rassemblement n'a
alors je vais soutenir les idées
racistes
il ya des présidents des présidents
mossi noir qui ont été raciste alors pas
lui aussi contre la pauvrété concrètes
vous nous en garde je lutte contre eux
et rêveront creuse